[Musique]
quand on prévient je veux développer la
franchise mister freeze au maghreb on
sait pas ce que tu veux dans l'est
aujourd'hui les boulangers anouk aimée
[ __ ] tu rends fou j'avais 8 ans pour
l'argent la semaine prochaine match voir
ma mère à son boulot ajouté m à la fin
tu les as pas je vous ai connu tu m'as
pas fait ça pour qui
on va monter en pro tour d'espagne
je sois toi frère moi jamais fait ça de
remontée du vélo je vais apprendre
moment des médailles toi d'accord mais
on espère maintenant que j'ai toujours
invités
les portes des coups de balai
be back my money back aux fins d'être
promu mer on n'avait qu'à dire non mais
pour moi tag heuer ou qu'ils aient peur
de nous qu'on regarde assez précieux
la vie c'est justement parce qu'on veut
nous renvoie la terroriste
tu as bien fait d'appeler ta mère
je suis fier tu es devenu un projet nome
[Musique]